we have to talk about the most hype
character in one piece Shanks since his
true identity and power have finally
been revealed so make sure to stay tuned
for that smash that like button if you
enjoy one piece videos like this one and
want to keep them coming make this the
video you join the knock if you haven't
already by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates you
can help me reach my insane goal of
reaching 2 million Subs here on YouTube
by clicking that one button and I would
be eternally grateful for that now thank
you to today's sponsor Marvel strike for
Squad RPG if you're like me you grew up
on Marvel cartoons like Spider-Man and
even have a Spider-Man poster on your
wall to this day and in that case Strike
Force offers you a fun and epic way to
keep the Nostalgia alive in a
contemporary gaming experience the game
allows you to be part of the most talked
about franchise in pop culture immerse
yourself in the Marvel Universe and
assemble your dream team and then go on
Epic Adventures Together think about it
you got characters you love that you
grew up with and now you can power them
up in a fun RPG game it's a dream come
true for any Marvel fan new players can
unlock up to 7 characters in the first
30 days including two of my favorites
Spider-Man and Deadpool so happy I have
them on my team the fights and story are
so exciting this game is definitely on
another level when it comes to the
Cinematic way your favorite characters
attack I personally love watching Spidey
use his webs to handle opponents the
visuals are stunning and you get an
engaging story too as you progress
through the levels making it feel like
you're in your own Marvel movie
alongside your favorite characters I
appreciate the strategy involved to
whether it's knowing when to heal your
team or which villain to tag team first
strategizing is definitely rewarding so
rather than rewatching the same show for
the fourth time this is a fun way to
spend your free nights strategizing
battling and exploring the Marvel
Universe yes it's a blast of a game but
it's also an entertaining Adventure
filled with characters you love so it's
ideal for your free time immerse
yourself in the Marvel Universe now and
for limited time only if you use the QR
code or click the link in the
description you'll unlock exclusive
characters for free by logging in
celebrate the upcoming release of Marvel
Studios the Marvels by unlocking Captain
Marvel for free also if you're a huge
spiderverse fan like me you'll be glad
glad to hear that Miles Morales is
available too until December 31st and
the really cool touch is that along with
the characters you can even unlock your
hero's favorite costume from Marvel
movies TV shows Comics and More in this
game so what are you waiting for click
the link in the description and unlock
these exclusive characters for free by
logging in right now and now without
further Ado let's jump into the epicness
spoilers and all so since I made my
hourong video about Shanks over a year
ago we got a lot of new groundbreaking
details to talk about including seeing
Shanks in action and his real identity
which proved a popular Theory correct as
we're about to get into during one of
the most recent chapters chapter 1095
and Beyond we saw flashbacks of the god
Valley incident where we know a
one-year-old Shanks was found by Roger
in a treasure chest before we saw this
flashback during chapter 1086 we saw an
old figar land Garling AKA St figar land
Garling not only is he a Celestial
Dragon AKA World Noble he was considered
the champion of God Valley and the
supreme commander of the God's Knights
who themselves enforce the law in
marijua and rank above the Marines in
other words they are powerful World
Nobles who can even punish the otherwise
Untouchable World Nobles now if you
didn't watch the movie One Piece red you
wouldn't have thought twice about the
name figar land however there was a big
clue in that movie about Shanks in the
movie The Five Elders say after finding
out UTA is shank's daughter that if she
has figur land blood this won't be so
easy at the time that implied Shanks was
a figure land but since didn't know much
about that Family it wasn't that crazy
of a bomb show but with the reveal of St
figland Garling that tied Shanks to this
man and implied that he was from one of
the most powerful and high ranking
Celestial Dragon families perhaps this
could have been shank's father
especially since he was at God Valley as
we'll see but to be fair it could also
be an uncle or some other kind of
relative as if not wanting to leave any
doubt about their close connection
though Oda gave us flashbacks of the god
Valley incident where we saw a young
Young figur Land Garling and yes he
looks a lot like Shanks and after taking
all this into account there can't really
be much doubt anymore Shanks is actually
Saint figur land Shanks not just a
Celestial Dragon but from one of the top
and most powerful Celestial Dragon
families now does that mean Shanks is
loyal to the celestial dragons not
necessarily I'm not here trying to talk
about shank's evil theories just look at
Luffy and GARP family members who can
choose drastically different paths and
just because Shanks is relative chose to
be a God's Knight and was a Celestial
Dragon doesn't mean he needs to be loyal
to the God's Knights just like Luffy
doesn't have to be loyal to the Marines
because his grandpa is a vice admiral
yet it's also not so obvious that Shanks
has nothing to do with the celestial
dragons anymore as we're about to get
into for instance you don't see Luffy
using garp's connections to get an
audience with the Admirals or something
like that the way Shanks did with the
five elders but more on that later so
now that we know Shanks is Saint figur
land Shanks it's time to look back at
his character in light of this new
discovery because everything starts to
make a lot more sense and to fall into
place once we know this I got it handed
to Oda though he did a good job of
making Celestial dragons in general such
a hatable group of people only to make
everyone's favorite character Shanks a
Celestial Dragon too in ongoing thesis
in one piece is definitely that your
circumstances at Birth need not
determine who you will become in the
future and Shanks is a great example of
that but back to chapter one where it
all started and I always thought that
the scene where the mount Bandit acts
like a big shot what Shanks was funny
Shanks and the crew because Shanks was
so strong even at the time and that
could still be a part of it no doubt but
knowing what we know now it also must
have been hilarious because our dude was
a Celestial Dragon while a nobody Mount
Bandit was throwing alcohol in his face
and causing a mess for him to clean up
we didn't know then but now we have a
good understanding of celestial dragons
if anything they act like the Bandit in
this situation bullying hurting and even
killing their slaves when they feel like
it and here you have a Celestial Dragon
being nice and putting up with the
Injustice even though he has the power
and in this world all the right to kill
this Bandit it's such a reversal of the
usual Celestial Dragon versus non-
Celestial Dragon relationship that you
can't help but laugh at the bizarre
situation this is one of the things we
love about Shanks even more so now that
we know the truth about him he may have
all the rights of the other celal
dragons as far as we know and as we'll
get to in this video but he refuses to
exercise them in most situations and
even goes out of his way to act sub
irent at times to avoid conflict with
nobody's not because he fears conflict
but because he doesn't want to kill
people unnecessarily now in most cases
as mentioned he doesn't need to rely on
his Celestial Dragon status because to
an extent the name he's built for
himself speaks volumes as well right now
he's currently the active yon with the
highest Bounty and even before that
Legends like Whitebeard were impressed
by his and mihawk's Duels but that's not
to say he doesn't ever use his Celestial
Dragon status to his Advantage we know
the the redhair Pirates attacked a
government ship with the now known to be
sun god NAA fruit and took the fruit
before Luffy ate it perhaps Shanks of
Celestial Dragon status helped him learn
about the truth about that fruit in the
first place cuz obviously not everyone
knows it and perhaps it helped him
discover that the fruit would be on that
ship at that time as well seems more
likely to me than assuming it's all a
coincidence and the reason we know that
yes he does rely on his Celestial Dragon
privileges at times is because of that
crazy marija meeting with the five
Elders no other pirate let alone yonko
could probably get such an audience let
alone at that time and be allowed to
leave after that so what they say when
shank shows up is the following and I
quote what do you want why would you
come all this way this is the Ry given
your standing you should have nothing to
do with politics we only arranged this
time on your request end quote then
Shanks replies and I quote I appreciate
that end quote then they ask to hear
what he has to say they even tell the
guards to leave them alone which is
crazy if you think about it and then
it's revealed that it's Shanks and he's
come saying he needs to talk to them
about a certain pirate so think about
how crazy this all is he was a Yono and
during the Ry the elders met with him
because he requested it now we know that
the elders are strong Fighters we saw
some of Saturn's crazy abilities
recently during the Egghead Arc so it's
clear that they didn't just agree to
this meeting because Shanks is strong
and forced them to and you can tell that
by shank's respectful tone as well they
did it because Shanks is a celest Dragon
it makes so much sense in retrospect and
clearly Shanks knows how to play the
role of a Celestial Dragon when needed
to because he is respectful to them
while he tried to get Marco to join his
crew in front of Whitebeard he shows
respect to the elders saying I
appreciate that now of course I refuse
to consider that Shanks is a traitor
that's working with the world government
so chances are he's just using his role
in status to his favor after all why
would a Traer steal the NAA fruit from
them and let Luffy get away with eating
it and it's more than just his Celestial
Dragon St status his figur land status
must give him extra privileges as we'll
see when we get back to figur land
Garling chances are he just wanted to
see if he can use the world government
to help him deal with their combined
enemy Blackbeard who seems to be
following in zeb's footsteps wanting to
be the new king of the world obviously
something that the world government
wouldn't be cool with then of course
there is shank's most famous moment that
we need to talk about the time he came
to Marine for to end the Paramount War
the craziest most star studded War we've
seen to date Shanks shows up and
effortlessly saves Kobe from Admiral
sakazuki then proclaims that he's come
to put an end to this war others are
shocked that after his recent scuffle
with Yono kaido yesterday he's already
here of course before the celestial
dragon reveal we attributed all this to
people fearing Shanks and his power and
of course Shanks is super powerful we
know about the mihawk duel and making
kaido turn back and we'll see his insane
power in action later on this video as
well but would that have really been
enough to make the government obey him
keep in mind it's not a good look at all
for the world government to cow toe to a
pirate it's much more believable that
his Celestial Dragon status played a
role in the sway he exercised over the
world's strongest organization sakazuki
says blast you redhaired you let Dragon
sun escape and Kuan and kizaru are
present too after a last attempt to hit
Luffy not Shanks mind you kizaru says if
they're still alive after that we'll
have to give up and just say they got
lucky but why why do three Admirals in
the world's strongest and ruling
organization have to give up other than
because of the fact that Shanks is a
Celestial Dragon and out ranks them
despite how upset sakazuki is he
uncharacteristically doesn't go after
Shanks he'd go after Whitebeard the
so-called strongest man in the world but
not after Shanks so you can't say it's
just because he fears shank's power
sakazuki is one who respects the
hierarchy even if he doesn't like it and
he knows he can go after St figer land
Shanks of all people and then of course
it ends when Fleet Admiral sen Goku also
agrees to end the war like shank said
but think about it we had sakazuki Kuan
kizaru senang Goku and GARP there among
others and perhaps the elders could come
as backups if needed not to mention the
holy Knights one can't just assume that
shank's power was the reason they cow to
to his demand in retrospect but when you
think about his figer land Celestial
status then the pieces start to fall
into place on the pirate side though
yeah I do think black was just like not
ready to deal with his strength even
during chapter 1055 after greenbull has
been so hyped up he just leaves when
Shanks Wills him to do it saying look
I'm not picking a fight with you guys
not yet fine fine end quote and he just
leaves keep in mind I don't know if
greenbull knows Shanks as a Celestial
Dragon we don't know how many people
would have that information but we do
know that Oda revealed through an SPS
that greenbull agrees with sakazuki
principles of never holding back when
battling enemies and we do know that he
believes the world Nobles truly are Gods
so an easy way to reconcile him
immediately retreating after a pirate
asked him to is that he knows of shank's
Celestial Dragon status then there's the
fight against the kid pirates the first
time we really saw shank's true power in
action and oh boy was it impressive and
embarrassing for the other side yeah we
heard of The mihawk Duel but we never
saw it keep in mind kid is coming off of
a Big W here he helped beat yonko big
mom and he was given a Yono level Bounty
as a result it's equal to Yono Luffy at
3 billion berries that's about 75% of
shank's bounty and after what happened
with big mom you may expect Shanks to at
least spend some time fighting before he
wins after all this is a show where it's
normal to fight for days if not longer
but no Shanks uses his Advanced
observation hockey to seemingly see 10
seconds into the future and then acts
quickly to finish kid before kid can
release his devastating attack he
quickly closes the distance and then
with his attack Divine departure he one
shots kid ending a pirate with a three
billion Berry Bounty and one who helped
defeat big mom in seconds clearly this
Show's Shanks is well above big mom's
level and reaffirms that you can't take
Bounty numbers as a sign of strength
obviously most of us knew this but like
I said this just confirms it after all
big mom had a higher Bounty than shank's
and it's clear that Shanks could have
destroyed her in battle I mean he even
made the socalled strongest creature in
the world turned back while he continued
on to the Paramount War himself if that
doesn't imply he was even stronger than
kaido then I don't know what does and
shank's power is not surprising when we
see what his potential dad or at least
relative is capable of St ferland
Garling is immediately set up as being
strong as he is the Supreme Commander
and thus likely the strongest of the
Gods Knights although with him too we
may have a GARP and Whitebeard like
decline meaning he's not at his prime
anymore but his prime was definitely
impressive back when he looked like
Shanks and was drooled over because of
his good looks he became the champion of
God Valley and we recently saw during
the god Valley flashback that he started
the competition at a disadvantage from
the beginning he was established as the
clear favorite with another competitor
stating I won't let you win Garling end
quote clearly knowing that he's the
biggest competition Garling even takes
the life of the king of God Valley
prematurely they say because of this
he'll start with minus 10,000 points
Garling is completely unfaced by this
though saying that should be a good
handicap for the other contestants does
this not give off sh Vibes right here
considering that Shanks was fine with
losing his arm to a mere seab Beast like
with Garling I think it's clear that
Shanks was confident that this wouldn't
make a difference for him and he too
probably thought that it should make a
good handicap for the other contestants
trying to go after the one piece and
although we didn't get to see what
happened later we did see that Garling
didn't even break a sweat when he found
out that people like the Roger Pirates
were coming all he said was Marines fall
back and protect the celestial Dragons
Holy Knights are with with me end quote
like GARP the Roger Pirates and the
Rocks Pirates it's hard to believe
Garling and His holy Knights didn't play
a significant role in this fight as well
clearly Garling made it out and with the
status of champion of God Valley so
despite the fact that he wasn't
mentioned by name like GARP and Roger
when the god Valley incident was
discussed before he probably did play a
meaningful role which is saying a lot
when you're dealing with so many big
players since the Rocks Pirates are
constantly being hyped up more and more
and since every time we see them Oda
only reveals more legendary p that were
on the crew I wouldn't be surprised if
GARP the Roger Pirates and Garling and
the holy Knights teamed up to finally
stop them after all we saw during
chapter 1096 that Garling was in the
thick of it so in a series where strong
characters usually have strong fathers
or at least relatives think Zoro for
that one it's not surprising that Shanks
does too there's no longer a doubt that
Shanks is related to figer Garling
garlings young looks confirm it while in
truth even the elders comments about
shank's daughter having figur land blood
made it pretty obvious as well so we
know now for certain after all those
years of theories that Shanks is in fact
a Celestial Dragon he is Saint figar
landland Shanks and like his probable
father before him he is incredibly
strong probably even stronger than
Garling just like I'm sure Luffy and
Zoro will surpass their ancestors too
and as we saw that huge Shanks reveal
also sheds new light on all of shank's
previous iconic moments everything makes
more sense now and in a lot of ways we
can appreciate some of those moments
even more now that we know Shanks is
true identity after all what other
Celestial Dragon let alone a high
ranking one would allow a weak Mountain
Bandit to humiliate him and then just
laugh it off whereas in contrast he
would get respect from the five Elders
with Shanks and now Bonnie recently as
well would has definitely proved that
being part Celestial Dragon doesn't
automatically mean you're going to be a
terrible person even if as a whole they
remain one of the most hated groups in
one piece now if the other yonko
interest you too including the yonko
that even the mighty Saint figar land
Shanks fear then you won't want to miss
my all Yono in their powers explained
video link on screen right now like And
subscribe to help me achieve my Shonen
level dream of 2 million subscribers
here on YouTube and I'll see you in the
next one